okay this is not a planned stream but
here I am streaming playing the VHS
shield rapid arena rapid shield arena
I've played a couple shield arenas this
week with not too much success except I
did finish in top ten I think in the
super blitz but this will be slower
chess I'm not gonna play the whole thing
it's an eight hour long tournament it
started about 45 minutes ago so there's
just over seven hours left
but I'll try and play some decent
quality games hopefully better quality
than the games I've been playing
recently so we're playing some kind of
weird Sicilian I enjoy throwing in this
move Knight c3 because it avoids some
variations of the open Sicilian like
with this fashion a cough okay so he's
playing g6 so he might be a dragon
player I'm gonna hold off I'm playing d4
and I'll play there should be 5 I'm some
kind of rustle [ __ ] we have the first sub
of today me and this army thanks for the
sub I'm gonna castle at some point I'll
probably take on c6 and hello to people
in the chats
hello German chess player 99 valley ryan
max gates and notes from ethiopia now
too many ethion Ethiopian viewers that
I've seen at least recently welcome so
you 6 makes me very happy
because the combination of e6000 and now
black has to decide what to take back
with and now I'll play d3 so I gave away
the bishop pair but
his bishops don't scare me
especially this bishop it's hard to
activate anytime soon and there's a
typical idea for whites which maybe I
should have considered last move is to
play e5 followed by 94 really trying to
hammer down on these some of these weak
squares so I might consider ePHI very
soon there's a move for block d5 which
looks natural and then sometimes white
wants to play rook be one night a for b3
and Bishop a3 some weird configuration
but it's aimed to target the c5 on so
sometimes black is better off playing d6
just to keep c5 defended I appreciate
the good luck wishes I appreciate all
the comments my uptime is only only
about two minutes so far
Filipino viewers well I have at least
one Filipino viewer I've been asking
where people are from at least more
recently and every time I ask it seems
very very diverse so a bishop basic so
he's trying to do something you might
want to play c4 but whenever you play c4
I play d4 so I don't have to go out of
my way to stop c4 I'm still intrigued
about this e5 move e5 because it gives
away some squares
yeah let's play e5
because I'm a bit bit more developed
than black
so sometimes it's okay like when you're
more developed you can start doing
things start attacking quicker and the
combination of my nights and my dark
squared Bishop is gonna be really nice
you got six even though it seems
defended by a lot of lack pieces could
be an issue and this bishops just gonna
be out of play like even if he plays c4
I play d4 and this Bishop side too so
one of the things about the bishop hair
needs to a position like this is that
like the positions close enough where
the Knights are just better and with e5
he pretty much has to bring the knight
it's a seven it's only logical
developing square and then I'll play 94
you could attack e5 with Queenie Queens
a c7 but then I have Bishop f4 so he
plays d6 okay actually pretty logical I
mean my first impression is to take and
play Knight e4 and keep initiative and
then the spawns gonna be very weak yeah
I'm not going to spend any time or not
much time as if he takes with Queen 94
and now the Queen's getting kicked and
the Queen has to probably stay defending
c5 and there's not too many squares to
go to if he plays Queen e7 I can
consider a Bishop g5 or a Bishop e3 or
Bishop f4 even realizing d6 could also
be weak live Queen e7 Bishop f4 already
threats of 96 or Bishop d6
our course 98 you wrote a PM to me I
will say I've been pretty overwhelmed
recently with just messages across it's
gotta be it across at least ten
different platforms between all social
media and Lee chess and chess calm and
email the best way or like the thing I
prioritize is email also thanks for the
bits Sarah nelio 500 bits again I will
also say I'm doing a Q&A stream coming
up I put together a stream schedule
finally which people can access on my
websites just I am rosen.com /schedule
so I'll try and do like either monthly
or bi-weekly Q&A streams to just answer
questions um Queeny seven okay so I have
my candor that moves Bishop III c4
Bishop c5 looks very attractive let's
just go with that
oh he could take on b2 ricky one that
still looks very attractive belgium
novice with us uh thanks for the sub
eight months in a row earlier today i
was designing like sub badges I might
redesign them though there are chess
pieces like someone meant like gave me
the recommendation and just courted to
have like pawn for the lowest level and
then work your way up like Knight Bishop
rook
okay so this position is really good
because c5 it's either a goner or he
plays c4 and then I just I'm invading
the dark squares and since the moment I
play II takes g6 I'm I'm just keeping
initiative an initiative I think is
gonna last many more moves if he takes
on b2 I make a threat I continue making
threats while winning things
yeah I remember struggling with like
Russell emo as black as I used to play
knight c6 on move to I would get into
these structures and then I just stopped
playing knight c6 and started like e6000
mobile but I guess if you're a Sicilian
player and you want to know what to play
against Russell emo just look at
Carlson's games he's had a good number
recently alright so Knight d6 King here
not gonna calculate too much I assume
Knight g5 maybe it's just about keeping
initiative like 95 yes to play Knight h6
Queen f3 looking for something a bit
more clear
so 95-96 Queen f3 Roca fades I mean okay
that looks really good
because I'm just developing with tempo
there's actually a funny variation night
age of six Queen f3 Roca fades and I
take on h7 the rook moves I moved back
and the only way to defend the pawn is
to return so I'm just keeping initiative
and I could even play like 94 or 98 c4
attacking the rook again and if the the
D file could open up like if I just take
on c4 and get a rook to d1 that looks
pleasant I forgot about f6 I should have
seen f6 and the first thing that comes
to mind is taking on e6 and taking here
and double attacking and I don't see how
black defends maybe rook c8 and rook c8
okay so funny line Knight takes c6 Queen
takes c6 Queen takes c6 rook c8 I can't
take on CA cuz it's in the night spin
but I take on a6 he takes on c5 and then
I play Knight b7 check attacking the
rook and also attacking the Queen
discovery and when he plays King d7 I
Fork
he just resigns oh I wanted to play that
line you might be watching the stream
and just being terrified like the arrows
just to show ya this would have been fun
I think at least fun for me was a rook
see a that looks tricky so I leave this
Bishop attacks but then here attacking
attacking attacking if King here I take
the rook or I play rook e1 or I take the
Queen and then take the rook actually no
rookie one rookie five but okay other
two options work okay so back to
tournament that was nice that's kind of
Russell [ __ ] game
tricky move order to that's one of the
reasons I like playing Knight c3
especially if like sometimes Blackpool
play some other open Sicilian like
against 93 you can't play the special
cough what else can't you play it just
opens up other options you got Jess with
200 bits
thanks you got Jess all right let's go
back and keep fighting I'm in in the top
400 almost a thousand players by the
time this tournament ends er is going to
be at least several thousand people join
over the course of next next seven hours
Patrick jmt is back
I should stay overseas cuz yeah I'm I'm
a night person I'm not a morning person
I'm a bishop person though but yeah when
I'm overseas like late evening is early
morning in the u.s. good news is is that
when I come back to the US I'll be super
jet-lagged and I'll still be awake in
the mornings at least for the week the
first week that I'm back
so yeah the morning streams will
continue for a little bit let's play
let's play another efore like you for 9
f 3
let's play some Italian and and play
this in a while h6 this guy probably
watches my comer videos if you go back
like st. Louis Chess Club YouTube
channel like comer is lecturing about
how you should play each six to stop
Knight g5 but h6 is just a slow move
like now this is a some sort of scotch
where a white will just be up a tempo
and h6 will be pretty much useless so
just more development and I'm white so
it's like two extra Tempe in the opening
so this is like the main position of the
scotch except we have h6 and Bishop c4
included also why did I not take on f7 I
could have taken off f7 and had Queen h5
but this line is looking nice too
is he five forget that I have time to
think playing really quickly well okay
if I was gonna cause some issues for
black like already Queen f4 in the night
is unpinned there's queen up for here's
Queen e7 castling
so I'm I don't think I'm winning a piece
but the position will be very good
better be very good
the problem with c5 is it's very
weakening to these squares and leaves
black with a kind of a backward pawn so
some day if the game lasts so long
I'll get it ripped to the half-opened
e-file so d5 yeah I looked at this move
briefly I assume okay at the very least
I'm winning on the winning a pawn so I
can take and then take on g7 at the very
most
I'm just winning everything wait this
should be fine mm-hmm I mean there's one
line which looks very simple just taking
takes and Queen e5 check Bishop e6 I
take on g7 I Castle I'm up a pawn life
is good let's do it
actually considering if he takes I can
play a queenie for also but that allows
King f8 the nice thing about if after
taking Queen e5 King f8 runs into taking
and I fork and I'm promoting which is
very nice loafs I did play in Melbourne
I did decently I drew my first four
games or five games
I drew my first four games and then I
end up finishing in third so it's a
decent result played a lot of chess in
Australia it's two back-to-back
tournaments with no rest days in between
so as 18 games 18 games and some days
had two games in one day so it's pretty
exhausting okay so I'm up a pawn I'm
expecting Queen g5 the Queen g5 I just
take the though and I have 94 forking
everything like 94 Wood fork both the
pawns
it would also fork to additional Forks
the king and the rook and also 96 a king
and all like the pawns and also yeah so
I'm gonna keep my extra pawn advantage
maybe when another pawn reminds me
slightly of the last game like my knight
going to e4 exploiting these weak
squares so he resigns Oh so two games
I think the first game was 15 moves this
game was 14 moves next game better be 13
moves I think my opponents are just
watching and they're terrified of the
arrows has to be the reason why they're
resigning
so I moved into the top 250 I'm white
again and white three times in a row
continue the theme with me for another
Sicilian okay let's play a close
Sicilian this time mix it up a little
bit me six usually I like to play f4 if
it's like Blitzer rap or bits or bullets
but this case I'll play Knight GE to a
bit more flexible I'm Alfie and Heather
this Bishop it's one difference between
this and some other variations of Knight
c3 Sicilian that the LightSquared Bishop
doesn't usually like to be on c4 staring
at the pawn more bits from Jacob sure
thanks for the bits so I've been playing
this move order because I am want to
stay flexible like I'm not sure whether
to do this or this let's play d4 have an
open Sicilian I'm curious if my opponent
plays this variation against like a
normal Sicilian like Knight f3 and
immediately d4 ok let's play Bishop e3
I was showing this to a student the
other day I have to remember what I was
showing I think I was showing like some
eventual lion with taking on c6 and
playing Knight 84 and c4 Oh Jacob said
those arrows seemed to be really scary
here's 300 bits to find more arrows I'm
pretty sure the arrows are free but bits
won't hurt
why didn't I check with the bishop in
the last game check with the bishop oh
if I played Bishop b5 there is 97 so the
knight would be saved
yeah so about a month ago I had a lesson
of the students and I'm pretty sure we
went over this exact position I have to
check it because we have the preparation
saved also had the lesson recorded but I
think I can take there's some tactics
like if he takes with Queen I have ie 5
and if he takes with pawn then things
will get positional and the combination
of Knight a 4 and c4 really has a
purpose to just create some clamp on the
position a lot more positional in nature
it's something like Marazzi buy and
setup I think I have to play rook e1
if I can't play c4 immediately I'll play
b3 III also undermines the rook and then
at some point black will choose like
which pawn to push because these puns
like not all of them are gonna stay
there
Bishop b5 so it looks like he wants to
take which might actually be a real
positional threat if I play Knight c3 it
blocks my seat on so I'm tempted to play
Knight b2 and then leave the bishop kind
of awkward let's do that and maybe I'll
go for a like c4 and put the knight on
d3
so I'm being cuddling my Knights sadly
this game is lasting longer than 13
moves so I'm not gonna win quickly so
the nature of playing positionally now I
would like to get my Queen off the D
file as he he might have some ideas of
d5 so let's put the Queen on c2
now d5 shouldn't work for multiple
reasons is this a free pond smells like
a free pawn takes and then retreats if
his rook wasn't on b8 if it was Sonny
would defend if it was on c8 he could
maybe play c5 but in this case yeah I
mean I feel like you're just going pawn
grabbing but I mean I pawn grab with
initiative and just move back so
blackouts to a file but I get a pawn
okay so his bishop is now unleashed but
c5 is a sign that he's probably not
gonna play d5 and my knight would much
rather it be on c3 and realizing my d3
it just has no purpose it's restricted
by blacks pawns so probably night 8 for
a knight a 4 2 C 3 and on c3 it does a
bunch of things it defends this pawn has
access to b5 discourages d5 defends a2
and this is kind of the main structure
that is expected from this opening
except usually black spot and still on a
seven and it's a structure where it's
like kind of a nice grind where white
can then focus on some D file pressure
and put the rook on do you wan maybe
I'll throw in a ch3 just to prevent
night g4 I'm very common like when the
bishop line III you just don't want to
deal with my g4 not that it would be a
huge issue but I think I can afford to
play slowly because I don't see any
active play from black and this is a
situation I should be playing more
quickly to like just play natural moves
keep improving thinking my bishop should
be on B - I don't see what it's doing on
e3 and then I'll have some double
fianchetto and maybe it doesn't do too
much for me - but at least it's not
blocking the rook and maybe I'll double
up on the D file
remember I had a game against actually
the highest rated player I've ever
played in a tournament was against
laQuan Leon who actually was a teammate
of mine for a couple years at Webster
University and he's top player from
Vietnam he popped like 30 or 40 in the
world and he completely outplayed me
with the black pieces and we have a very
similar structure but reversed where he
he was the one applying d-file pressure
and he beat me with like a really nice
idea because I like hunkered down and
defended and at some point I put my
Queen where I was blocking my Bishop and
then he played Knight d5 Wow so I might
have this in in this position 95 with
idea that if the trade happens and the
bishops trapped and it's just a way for
white transform the position and get
some more advantage
so does 95 actually work looks
reasonable this other idea I want to
just remove this Bishop which weakens
blacks dark squares yeah let's go for it
I'll have to find this this game that I
played against him because I thought I
was being solid and was just so it was
really very instructive like the way he
just built up pressure I found this
Knight move and then just destroyed me
okay so I'm winning the bishop you can
win a pawn for it but now this bishop is
just breathing fire the problem is like
if he takes with Knight then it loosens
this pawn I'm already considering like
taking on f6 and then taking on h7 but
then there's weird tactics maybe I
should
so take on d5 like okay this is a
position to calculate concretely because
Bishop takes d5 might just win on the
spot threatening the Queen and also
threatening Bishop takes f6 Queen takes
h7 and the line to calculate this takes
takes takes I'm training mates a few
different ways if you plays Knight f6 I
Chuck Knight g8 takes g7 and I win like
that so let's do it
I mean if he moves as Queen I taken win
h7 and I'll be up another pawn with some
attack I don't think I'm missing
anything
this is coming I mean it's amazing one
throughout Angie Sutton's hanging and
the nights hanging you could play f6 I
just take the night or do I check first
check on each 500 just take the nights
yeah this is just positional domination
why does up two pawns this Bishop is so
depressing
okay he has counterplay on the queenside
I guess I'm thinking queen g6 followed
by rook h5 work h8 mates does that looks
hard to stop
so Queen g6 work takes a to work h5 King
g8 and I have Queen Yeates bishop f8
should be good enough
I didn't calculate till the end there
but I mean with my rook on the e-file
something should work
there's a nice line rook takes a to rook
h5 King g8 Bishop takes f6 because if
Bishop takes f6 it's meat and otherwise
I'm just I mean that six pawn goes away
it's just winning there's also Queen h7
ideas
he takes the rook what was scared of
rook h5 I guess it's taking on f6 work
it's a sub thank you what I don't know
how to pronounce that hitch hitch I
chalk 21
okay I don't think there's any need to
think too long I've just up a queen
okay that was nice feel good game the
idea is that I've seen before extended
well into the middle game like the whole
idea of taking on c6 and putting the
pawn on c4 and then even later like
pressurizing the the D file and then 95
all ideas which are good to know for
this structure Hart why is a new goal
thanks for the sub and or thanks for the
bits and Night Moves things for the sub
just to add blue in the chat okay so
before I go on to the next game I do
want to try and find this game that I
played so we're gonna go to Google
kwan/wong Liam Leigh Rosen I think the
game was played in 2014 it should be on
chests bomb just bomb
I think this is it yeah this is it
so if you find a game online like this
and you can't download the PG n the best
thing to do if you want to analyze it
because chess bum like you can't analyze
the news I'm just gonna copy the whole
notation and then I will go back to Lee
chess I will make a new study I'll make
it completely public so people they want
to access that they can getting crushed
by a super GM and then we can just go
and pay some notation this better work
hey it works and then we can even add
names like below the board just just for
the people who aren't watching like
people in the future that stumble upon
this study I'll add the PG intetics out
a new tag so white is me and black
laQuan me I'm his name he actually goes
by limb or Liam oh wait I made that the
black reading got the black player okay
so now we have the names here just a
little bit it's just a show like how
similar this game is to the game that I
just played we're gonna zoom through in
the middle game completely different
opening symmetrical English with early
d5 and then we got a structure which
should start looking very similar so the
position I just had but reverse very
similar
like compare this position to okay I won
the a pawn but like compare this
position to this position pretty similar
meat just org is following thanks Lee
chest I'll work pretty sure that's
officially chest channel to spuds with a
sub thanks fudge oh yeah Lee Strasburg
in the chat the only and the only VIP in
the chat Lee chest I work is the only
VIP on stream or on my stream so Queen
c2 yeah okay so this is where I was
hunkering down I was feeling solid and
then ninety four out of nowhere which I
just missed during the game it's so
strong because it has ideas of taking
both these and then maybe winning d3
Howard pawn with bits so I took with the
Bishop with ideas to play E for now this
is a good spot if people want to pause
and find the best move for black I had
the notation up briefly but black to
move in win material such a nice move
for black I'll let people in the chat
try and find it
before I move on if I put this on
YouTube the YouTube people can pause the
video to looks like a loafs found it
says BX which I assume is Bishop takes
and there's only one Bishop capture
nerve on Raymond also found it yeah
Bishop takes e4 it's always like a
tactical clue if your Bishop is aligned
with the Queen and you want to look for
ways to exploit it and I miss this
during the game too after I take back or
I didn't take back but if I do take back
this really hurts me double attack and
black is winning stuff so yeah he's a
good player I played h3 and it was a sad
position I fought on for a while
but black was just cruising with the a
pond somehow I won the a pawn but then
he he simplified into just a of winning
endgame up up on like all it took was
one coin for luck to win so okay if
people want to look at this you can
analyze on your own in the movie chess
study but anyway let's go back to
tournament I'll play a few more games
try and keep the streak top 200 now I'm
finally black the first three games I
was white let's play d5 I'm not gonna
play my normal garbage just gonna play
kind of my main repertory my main
tournament opening is Sicilian but II
five is has it at least recently become
of a secondary line that I play so I'll
play a six will play main line might
have six seven
so this is where black should play d5
when white plays rookie when he's
threatening to take on c6 and weenie 5
and now I'll Castle if he allows me to
play a marshal I'll probably play a
marshal like c3 would allow the marshal
a3 I don't think I've seen before
a3 I mean a4 is like a common anti
marshal a3 mean I'm curious here if like
I can still get away with playing a
marshal I don't know how effective it is
because c3 is usually detrimental for
whites there's a box knife from coming
outs so d5 takes takes takes takes takes
takes takes and then c6
I don't know I could play Bishop b7
maybe that's reasonable
I could play D 6 D 6 also looks
reasonable gives up on any martial ideas
usually when they play a3 they want to
put the knight on c3 so I'm trying to
like figure out the differences between
d6 and Bishop b7 there should be seven
93 94 takes takes let's put the bishop
on b7
thinking if c3 has played then I play
this and then it's Marshall like I was a
little bit hesitant to play d6 because I
didn't want to commit not to playing d5
Captain Riker with a sub thanks Captain
Riker no I'm thinking again d5 I could
just play this like a briar - but defy
look at d5 we trade he takes takes takes
and then I think the move would be
usually I want to play like Knight f4
but there I probably play Queen d6 first
doesn't seem right
let's just play d6 we'll have a slow
game play positional the Briar is a
variation at least in the mainline where
black players might be a to d7 which
I'll probably go for yeah I'm gonna go
for that it feels weird like undeveloped
thing but the night is just better on g7
and the bishop becomes happier also
allows for maybe c5 maybe c6 restricting
the night
now I feel like somehow we've transposed
into some actually I don't know if we
transpose with maybe what I'm doing is
weird but this setup I've seen played
before like very high level like
Grandmaster play I assumed this was
reasonable there's also some idea Knight
d7
to c5 okay so he is going forward I
probably don't want to allow Knight
takes Bishop because if I lose my darks
crate Bishop and his Bishop becomes
powerful so I'm tempted just to take
taking looks very reasonable I'm taking
this guy really seriously even though
he's like rated 1760 there's a way he's
playing the opening it's uh I know if I
were playing like a GM I'd be
second-guessing every move I and making
but now I'm feeling comfortable like now
we just trade Bishop so I'll go for f5
and put the Knights back into play I
always have to double-check that when I
play off five I not allowing this knight
to come to e6 in this case the knight
has no path to e6 now if i play my
Knight to d7 and eventually to f6 I
should probably preface it with h6 just
not allow this
I like the structure like this pawn on
d5 it controls space but it's also kind
of a weakness
oh maybe white can justify it like c4 B
4 B 3 okay let's play this another idea
that 5 is to maneuver the Queen into
play and start organizing some attack
these pawns are control a lot of space
and advance further at some point with
f4 and one move that white would like to
play it but probably just doesn't work
as d4 to try and open the center but
then I just play e4 so let's start with
Queen Yeats
see nation Ches asking would this
technically be an improved session a
call structure because black has a C
pawn to backup the d6 plot mmm and the
specially called what is black missing
all blacks missing the C pawn yeah I
kind of vaguely know what you're
referring to it's definitely like
Pleasant as a structure it's hard to
break that's very hard for a white to
play c5 even he's trying time to gain
space he'll start with Queen g6 but if I
play queen g6 he can take and then start
attacking the C pawn the thing in the
special akov there's no C pawn to attack
but now he has some targets so I'm
wondering if I should just take first
and then play queen g6 to keep the C
file closed seems a little more
attractive actually you know it's - its
I mundo being white spawns so it looks
like I'm helping him but I just want to
minimize any any initiative for white on
the Queen side well maybe he'll go for
this in this Oh every move I should be
considering me for should also be trying
to figure out how I just make threats on
the Kings side because I probably don't
want to play e4 unless it has some clear
purpose I mean maybe I want to play f4
first to prepare efore and then f3
realizing maybe I should have played
queen h5 to allow the rook lifts there's
also some idea just like Knight f6
Knight h5 9 f4 so he's going for c5
there's also okay this probably it's not
good but I have like 90 593 ideas so
lots of ideas
you go play Knight f6 trying to improve
the Knights I'm liking this maneuver
also thinking that maybe at some point I
could play this distract the knight into
the center and then go for like some
more attack with the knight not
defending h2 I should pay attention to
time too it's 10 minutes it's a lot of
time compared to the previous chest that
I've been playing that it's still not
that much time Wow very tricky move if I
take he wins he 7 meanwhile he wants to
play 96 very clever thinking I should
just allow 96 and play around the night
what's the best way I'll start with rook
f7 okay so he's getting his dream night
there's some crazy line I'm calculating
96 night here
I take c7 at the very least I ever
exceeds I could play h3 though to do
that's why work see it first
looks awkward
what the goal is to try and make this
night just a decoration like make it
look pretty but get a situation where
it's just not doing anything and I feel
like it's already kind of the case where
I can very easy start focusing on the
kingside and there shouldn't be too much
to worry about me maybe Queen a for
going after this pawn but then I'll just
I don't know it's gonna be sharp Queen a
494 hmm C to start with Queen h5
trying to figure out what my next move
is an IG for it always runs them to h3
f3 so this gives me some possibility to
play like g5g for I have to rely on some
intuition here but g5 it's also
weakening like Queen h4 allowing not h5
let's start with g5 maybe I'll do this
and this and just storm oh i blundered a
pawn though or did I
I completely forgot that 5s no longer
defended but I might be lucky in the
sense that if he takes on that 5 I can
take on d5 simultaneously attacking the
Queen and defending my Jeep on so I
think it's ok so that was a happy
accident assuming he's not destroying me
here but if it works I'm dislodging I
should very soon dislodge the Knights
maybe even chop the Knights
I mean the very least night off for will
come we'll trade and gee file opens
things are very happy now this is a nice
discovered attack and discovered defense
they should feature this on the
Discovery Channel you might play like
queen g4 and then we trade queens Knight
b6 c4 ISM defended at least she's
thinking and my time advantage it's
growing okay so we're gonna trade Queens
or do I play queen g6 no my nights
hanging sighs should take okay so this
line is gonna happen Knight b6 or Knight
f4 y4 we trade Knights Knight b6 Oh
Knight b6 I'm threatening the plot I'm
also threatening this other than he
takes four g6 ah what to do let's do
this keep things interesting
and more complex it's kind of a
practical decision like he's a bit lower
on time I feel like I should be better
at handling the time scramble I think
well I'll do very soon is play h6 like
maybe even right now defending g5 and
preparing or cossacks
if he plays rook efore attacking my
knight I play d5 defending and attacking
and I probably continue with d4 and then
wreck of sex
I apologize if I'm putting people to
sleep I hope that's not a bad thing if
anything hopefully it's a good thing if
it's bad time for some people
okay so d4 was my first impression
d4 actually traps the bishop I was so
focused on chopping the night but
somehow the bishop is unexpectedly
trapped he's probably just gonna take
and win a piece for a couple pawns ah
rookie for tricky tricky
now I dropped the knight wait what's
going on things are actually getting a
little bit unclear so you can take on d4
I think it's okay though he takes on d4
it depends what he takes with Dix with
Bishop I just take his knight takes that
way I just take and play rook yeah I
broke out for is nice
cuz now if he takes my bishop I take his
bishop otherwise we trade rooks
you used to listen to you sir to fall
asleep I can probably say the same
what to do maybe he just takes in King
f7 it's a three s attacks and he has
discoveries with the bishop but I don't
think there's anything too harmful I
could take a three I could play
ninety-two let's take a three I'll have
an outpost on b5
yeah life is good time is good things
are solid
try and organize a mating net of some
sorts
okay no need to be fancy let's just take
when the b-pawn
okay interesting game I feel like I
should look at the opening because a3 I
think it's it's a logical move but it's
rare and I don't play the Spanish enough
to be prepared for a move like this so
there should be seven wait let's look at
masters together base I'm gonna quiz
myself though I'm like what the most
common moves here are most common move
should be C 3 followed by I would say D
3 a 4 h 3 d4 Knight c3 and then maybe a
3 let's see masters Davis so C 3 ok H 3
o H 3 is more common than d3 but a 4 and
d4 okay so a 3 is in the vicinity and
yeah I'm not surprised that like various
strong players have played this move
Carlsen included I think the idea is
because usually in the Spanish white
plays C 3 and looks a bishop back on C 2
when the Knight attacks it so the idea
with a3 is to keep the bishop along this
diagonal to face a king and then
continue with ideas like Knights d4 or
Knight c3 to d5 so what should i do I
played Bishop b7 not the most common
move I was probably right in not playing
d5 so this should be 7 D 3 d6 white
score as well but somehow it transposes
into Oh Carlton Caruana
2015 might be a not so common real quick
Carlson Caruana Queen d7 looks natural
trying to figure out like why Queen d7
would be played I don't know the media
reason I mean that connects it rooks it
looks like a natural move I don't know
if there's any like details I'm missing
Oh to play 98 okay answer was in the
next move 98 interesting maneuver to get
to e6
it's the maneuver I actually mentioned
in my game where I was thinking like
this long maneuver which takes four
moves this only takes two moves so
that's actually really really clever and
the knight is well placed on d6 given
this pawn structure mt5 okay interesting
way to claim
I'll keep this in mind because this is
usually a maneuver you don't see every
day in the Spanish for a black knight
dat six alright let's play at least one
more game let's go back close some tabs
here and then back to tournaments try
and break into the top hundred I've had
three whites and one black so far
white games have been nice that last
game was probably the most challenging
game and now I'm white again every game
I've played has been an e4 game another
a5 okay if he lets me I'll play a
Spanish so this time I'm playing Spanish
is white he's playing the Berlin I
actually studied the the Berlin some
really weird sideline for a tournament
I'm gonna try and remember it
but he's playing g6 the main move is
Knight takes e4 actually don't know why
D six is not played maybe just d4 I
could also play rook e1
I assume the idea is to play Bishop g4
early so I'll probably allow
let's play rookie one doesn't seem like
I can go wrong with that
defend the partner Mike is slipping okay
Bishop e7 so we'll have some I think
relatively standard Spanish position are
we transposing now we're not transposing
because et hasn't played a six yet I
think I'll play h3 now because I want to
play d4 sometimes d4 is met with Bishop
g4 or even take some vision g-force loss
by age three restricting the bishop
because now the bishop doesn't have any
like attractive squares if it goes east
six it's just running into problems d7
is kind of passive
so let's retreat all right so we're
actually transposing into kind of
mainline Spanish except I've saved a
tempo because usually in mainline
Spanish white plays Bishop b3 and then
later plays Bishop or c3 Bishop c2 so
now I'll play d4 or do I play d3
that's way d4
take it's common for black to at some
point play
c5 Caroline Knights d2 and the typical
Spanish maneuver is might f1 to g3 I
might go for b3 Bishop b2 looks
reasonable and then the combination he's
letting me take not going to take though
it's going to say the combination of the
bishops and the Knights they can combine
well for a King side attack and b3 is
gonna come with tempo - I'll probably
play d5 its gain space and restrict this
Bishop now the bishops just staring at a
pawn chain and both black bishops are
pretty sad in this position and at least
one of my bishops will be happy okay so
he's going for a Bishop f6 looks very
reasonable actually mine e7 good move
wanting to go for this e v square so I'm
thinking Knight g3 allowing Bishop f6
and rip b1 now let's start with Knight
g3 I'm staying flexible I'm not sure if
I want to go for this or if I want to
put the bishop on one of these squares
their ship c3 wall
see three looks odd I'm just gonna play
rookie to the bishop should be hit at
some points black should lose time I
still want to attack f6 makes me very
very happy because II six is now week
I'm trying to figure out how I get in 96
like 9h five neither 496 one idea
there's also some attempt to trap the
bishop I might have to be patient
I'll have Knight a5 right away attacking
the pawn how does he defend 95
I want to take too long on this move but
feel like it's critical moments so nice
h4
you know play night h4 I feel like this
is most flexible I keep the option open
of night I 5 I'm also having still ideas
of night h5 to f4
I'm also unleashing the pawn so if he
plays like Bishop e5 I can throw in f4
and I'm now controlling the e5 square so
he doesn't have a piece to just be happy
there here's a d4 square I'm probably
King h1 f5 so attacking my knight but I
think I can just take this pawn pretty
sure that was a plunger and now the
bishops attacks I can take it
wait Knight h5 and go after g7 that
actually looks really nice
oh wait I can't win g7 though I forgot
the bishop moves backwards
I could play g4 next that would be
something I could just take the bishop
and then defend the Knights I don't
really want to trade off my nights from
f5 though so I'm leaning towards playing
g4 what's crazy let's do it
I don't see anything wrong with it maybe
he'll play g6
and very soon I'll take on d4 so the
bishop doesn't have a great place to to
run away to I could have taken on d6 but
then he takes on each five things we get
weird here I just take on d4 and now the
great thing is my dark squared bishop is
so happy because he doesn't have a dark
for addition to contest it his light
squared bishop and his knights and his
rook I just also said and g7 is gonna be
the target expecting like Knight f6 yeah
and I can just take and play Bishop b2 I
could play Knight g3 but why not
simplify Oh Bishop b2 he takes in wins
f4 so let's just trade Queens
I'll be very controlled so I'm up to
pawns here can gain a little more space
if I want
play Bishop b2 I mean probably the main
plan is to control the C file so let's
Oh
there should be two losses upon so maybe
Bishop III I'm holding off on playing g5
because I think it helps them improve
the rook
he wants his works connected to fight
for the file
I guess I'll still get the rook to see
it put the bishop on d3 now I should
move quicker if rook c8 I probably just
trade now let's play Bishop g4 rook c1
will come oh wait bishop d4 just loses a
pawn what am i doing well what am i
doing well I'm making the game more
interesting I'm only up one pawn that
was a really like important pawn to oops
well it's F pawn gambit he's controlling
the F file I'll play I'll still fight
for this C file get the rook to c7 the
bishop is still out of play
ah the Knights coming in 9 H for King H
2 should be okay
if only I could go back in time it was
so nice when I had that five there
should be four maybe there's a d4 looks
fun so how is he defending g7 he takes
d3 I'm meeting him or am i text III
takes King h8 rook maybe I'm not Wow
maybe a four
or Bishop c2 so you have a threat if he
doesn't have a threat I should play
Bishop c2 on pinning this bishop
game is definitely more interesting now
rook f1 that makes me happy because now
I think I have this oh but he has Knight
f3 Czech scary okay now I'm scared but
my f3 is only one check so maybe a four
to move quicker too
let's play for
now see what he's up to
there's one like tactical trap in the
position maybe you'll fall into
he's debating here between night h4 and
ninety-five probably or even 91 hmm we
might repeat at least like once so I'm
at age 14 age 2 wondering if maybe he's
playing for a win though about time
situation
a combination of night plus two rooks
can be very scary
at least I'm controlling g1 so there's
no immediate like mating ideas I like
the facts he's thinking just keep
thinking for another four minutes
91 wait can I take and play Bishop d4
has that enough compensation taken
Bishop d4 rookie to King g3 no more
checks I'm winning g7 and I forgot
suddenly just when the bishop I'm
getting a good position why it could
just be completely winning here or I
could just be missing something but this
looks really nice for whites because g7
like if he allows rook g7 then King h8
there should be something okay so the
positions transforming down the exchange
for a pawn temporarily and as rook is
tied down to the fighting the bishop
which currently has no squares like all
these squares are controlled and there's
no good way to defend g7 I'm expecting
he's gonna try and bail out with this
like sacking oh but then I still take on
g7 and meet him that's nice so I don't
know what he's gonna do
there's some funny line like rookie to
King g3 rook d2 takes arrows are off
today and then King h8 I can't meet him
because he has ripped takes t4 but I can
play Bishop a1 and he can't attack the
bishop or can he
maybe he can maybe I would play Bishop
b2 but then takes on c2 I'll figure it
out you might be watching shouldn't say
too much
I'm still trying to figure out this line
avoiding thinking out loud
feels like some endgame study
it's crazy liens okay now I officially
have the time advantage much more fun to
position to play for whites being upon
time plays this move which I kind of
figure out it out I think I can just
take and move back and black this should
still be stuck maybe pre move this
maybe my king should be improved to
improve this way too
also some idea of playing this and then
get the bishop in and meet or just flag
him each five
well I don't see anything wrong with
just taking the pawn like he can't use a
G file and now I have a passed pawn
I think that was an attempt to to bluff
me and now this is very hard to stop
threatening me than to this will be a
nice finish I'll play Bishop g7 meats
good promotes it's okay so not the
smoothest finish there is a line towards
the end there which I was trying to make
sense of and I didn't see a win for
white so I didn't want to like say it
out loud in case he was watching but it
was in this position I think I mentioned
it briefly but with rook t2 attacking
the bishop allowing rook takes g7 and
then after King eight shades I don't
have any like immediate bins because
whatever Brook move I play he just takes
the bishop so I was singing Bishop a1
with idea okay I'm threatening mates and
he can't attack the bishop with this
rook but he can attack the bishop with
the other rook and my bishop kind of
runs out of squares
it's a bit unfortunate I can't go to see
3 or B 2 because then he just takes here
so I don't know what's going on like if
he plays rook t2 I think this is the
best try maybe I take on g7 with the
bishop
yeah taking on ji-sun with the bishop
looks good enough and rocky eight have
two pawns for the exchange Bishop h6 and
his bishop still stuck and there's some
nice kind of defense like this defends
this defends this defends this real
quick let's see what's Aakash says after
at D - I was showing Bishop a1 briefly
oh it doesn't like taking on g7 oh
because rook takes C - yeah that's
strong so it's just saying
rook D - so Bishop a1 every way rook
takes g7 doesn't work so bishop they
wanted medially well rook f1o work out
when I can take the bishop hmm yeah
weird position should not have blundered
f4 okay but interesting game hopefully
that was instructive he's most of the
game shows how to build up this attack
on the Kings side I kind of forgot that
the chat existed but nice to see people
are still here I recommend something bad
to confuse him I've done that before on
streams attorney like fake my opponents
out who I think might be watching well
then it confuses the viewers - okay so
I'm tired it's 108 a.m. in Thailand so I
think I'm gonna end it here I have a
stream schedule now so people can look
at my schedule there should be a
schedule command but you can just go to
my website I am rose and
komm click schedule or just backslash
the schedule
I believe that protesting is going on
right now so I'm probably going to raid
them so you just verify twitched slash
Ches
yeah they're live okay so I'm reading
twitch.tv slash chests have fun watching
them and thanks guys for watching
appreciate the viewers as always